let's bring in some experts to talk
about that mark Fuhrman's with us former
detective of the LAPD knows as good as
anybody how to break this stuff down and
if any clues were dropped or balls drop
John under Ellie's also here retired FBI
special agent and former FBI national
spokesperson let's start with you if I
can mark mark you saw this situation
people who like to look back that never
worked a case before like you have and
said how could they miss these signs I
actually don't think that's the case
here do you know I don't there's many
times when somebody does drop the ball
maybe multiple times but this is not one
of them
if in fact I think they went way out of
their way when they contacted her at 142
in the morning to actually contact her
father 39 year old females that are
obviously in control of their faculties
are not missing she knows where she is
she's driving her vehicle she knows what
she's doing and she can leave anytime
she wants so I don't believe they did
anything wrong John as you see somebody
this is not usually we use we don't
usually see females no history of
violence she had her gun legally she was
stopped she was found sleeping in her
car hours before the shooting do you see
any signs that I would miss because I
haven't been trained absolutely not
the police made an inquiry and just like
Mark said to actually pick up the phone
and call the family on somebody who is
clearly an adult to reassure them that
she's okay likewise if the family had
any knowledge including of the weapon I
have not heard a word about that too yet
yeah a couple of things mark my sense is
watching these videos hearing that she
was protesting in February about YouTube
taking her stuff down randomly shooting
I sense the family knows a lot more
about how unhinged this shooter was do
you get that sense I do I think the
family knows a lot like maybe many
families that have problems with
somebody inside of their family they
want to keep that close to the vest and
maybe not express their fears and that's
exactly the problem nobody really knew
what her mental state was and she was
obviously not in
a good mental state she tried to commit
multiple homicides and then she killed
herself
John do you take anything do you look
into the family a little bit more you
know after the you know after the pulse
shooting after the San Bernardino
shooting you say okay who are they how
do they get here who are they related to
and you know because they are the family
what did come here as refugees do you do
you want to see you want to know more
about this case if you since this is
just one woman who lost her mind and is
now dead regardless of where the family
comes from this is a case where police
and law enforcement in general is going
to look into everybody who's connected
with this person violent crimes were
committed we want to know are there
other people that may be supplied the
weapon knew what her intentions were or
even egged her on all that has to be
determined alright I got to ask you
something else and it popped into your
security knowledge you know at Fox after
9/11 I used to be able to walk in every
book door here now I cannot get in this
building without a pass even though I've
been on television for 20 years just the
way it works here is YouTube one of the
most popular companies in the country
the most successful why is this person
allowed to penetrate that deep where's
the security that did it that occur to
you at all because I'm telling you right
now I don't want anyone to challenge it
but we have layers of security here so
to see it and so do others don't you
think people got to wake up a little
Marc well YouTube certainly had security
personnel but they did not have a way of
stopping this person from getting
through the garage the reality is that
they need to secure that area
for these types of events in the future
because it could happen again Marc you
know sometimes security is just that
visible security it's one layer at the
front door a front desk a security
officer but then you need multi layers
of security starting with outside of the
parking structure video surveillance
people outside people inside people
inside the inner workings of the
building so most corporations have kind
of a visible security they do not have
deep security all right and lastly when
I look at this woman and I understand
that the family try to try to give
everybody a heads-up
was too late how do you possibly
legislate mental health and gun
ownership she had the gun legally
clearly she's not mentally stable
she thought the YouTube was personally
going after there's a paranoia here does
anyone want to take a shot at that John
well you can make all the gun laws you
want but the reality is in this country
we're ignoring the mental health issue
in every one of these cases that's been
a common factor and we need to address
that we need to be able to make those
records available when background checks
are done so that we can prevent people
who are mentally ill from having access
to weapons and Mark I don't know if
there's a way to stop that unless the
family really wants to get aggressive
and said I have a hunch she's never
she's never showed violence tendencies
before but I think we gotta take the gun
away personally I mean I actually don't
know how you stop this well Brian you
got you have hundreds of thousands of
people that have tried to commit suicide
that threatens suicide and one of the
ways that make suicides so devastating
is when they want to take multiple
people with them and then commit suicide
so we already know and we have had for
decades known through psychiatry and
different programs the people that are
suicide prone and have attempted and we
really can't do anything with them we
can't incarcerate them permanently we've
lost that ability so really there's not
a whole lot you can do yeah where we
were looking at the school and where the
balls were dropped and where we go from
here I think that this is this is a
narrative buster guys thanks so much
appreciate it thank you thank you